tonight Oscar pistorius's manager
describes his aggressive behavior his
love of guns and his high speed driving
he would then refer back to me
remember what happened to you in 2007
and he wanted to ensure that we are safe
and not being followed and how the
London Olympics turned him into a global
icon as famous as Usain Bolt welcome to
the high court in Pretoria where Oscar
Pistorius his defense is entering its
final stages today the court heard from
Pete fan sale the athletes manager mr.
fan sale painted an intimate picture of
a man obsessed with security and guns
and he described how his gold medal
winning performances at London 2012
vastly increased the money you could
earn from endorsements and sponsorship
Ashish Joshi reports
Oscar Pistorius arrived at court knowing
much of the morning session would be a
forensic examination of his personality
we would learn in intimate detail more
about the athletes temper his love of
guns and his security paranoia we would
also discover more about his
relationship with reeva Steenkamp the
model girlfriend who Oscar Pistorius
shot dead on Valentine's Day last year
the details were provided by Oscar
pistorius's manager Pete Vaughn sale a
close confidant and friend who had
shared the runners life for the past
eight years the defense began by asking
mr. font sale to describe his clients
obsession with personal safety through
all the interaction I had with mr.
Pistorius over the years and it was very
evident that and for me the best way to
describe it is basically a heightened
sense of awareness so if I can enlighten
the court with specific instances we
would travel to the airport and mr.
Pistorius would be driving quite fast
coming to pick me up at home and and
always offered that I can leave my car
at home and we just drive with his car
and he would drive quite fast to the
airport I would think
inquire from mr. Pistorius there's no
rush least we got enough time to make it
to the airport and he would then refer
back to me stating that remember what
happened to in 2007 when I after another
trip that we did was hijacked Edgar
excuse me at gunpoint and had a very
traumatic experience and he wanted to
ensure that we are safe and not being
followed whenever we had to park in
specific can we call it parking vice at
the airport or for instance at an event
that we had to go to he always ensured
that he parked in a open space
easy access even an enlightened space
way there was enough light if it was was
was at night so that he could always
feel safe and secure we were in New York
in 2011 at the
iwf Diamond League and we were walking
down the street just in New York and
heard a loud noise a bang and which I
just basically reacted and inquisitively
trying to find out what it was we looked
around to see where the noise came from
whereas in the stories these guys
grabbed me by the arm which was very
unusual for me and then suddenly just
released again and we just kept on
walking but it was just strange for me
that he would react in such a way that
he would grab me when something like
this happened we had a few occasions
where sometimes late at night I would
receive the schedule for the next day's
events whether it be for a photo shoot
or sponsors commitment or something
similar I then went to mr. Pistorius
room to give him the necessary
information and by knocking on the door
he always asked first who is at the door
and then secondly when he opened the
door the door wasn't not only just
locked but always had the latch on which
was also for me interesting being in a
safe environment that you always had the
left on
apart from just normal knock on the door
we had often spent time at mr. Pistorius
residents to discuss either contractual
obligations or also looking at the
competition schedule for the season
and whenever we were sitting around the
dining table and it sometimes even was a
bit annoying for me that I could never
keep him focused on as he was always
looking around asking his housekeeper if
the front door was locked
asking where the dogs are so always
fidgety if I can describe it in such a
way and in going to restaurants coffee
houses and so on yes stories always
ensure that he took a seat at a table
way he had a clear access and view to
the entrance and exit of a restaurant as
an international athlete Oscar Pistorius
travel the world attending races and
fulfilling sponsorship obligations the
schedule was exhausting and as his fame
and celebrity spread more demands were
made on his time according to his agent
the double amputee was keen to involve
reeva Steenkamp in his plans as much as
he could one reason was to stay close to
her but the other was to give his
girlfriend an insight into his world to
show her the pressure he was under and
the strain had put on his relationship
with people if you had occasion to meet
miss Denker I did meet with um come tell
the court about that and how many
occasions for instance I can't recall
the specific number of occasions but I
didn't meet misty and come on a number
of occasions and with mr. Pistorius at
different venues and seeing through your
eyes what was the relationship like for
me I would describe it as a loving and
caring relationship mr. Pistorius and
mr. camp was always calling each other
pet names as well that they involve in
this career
yes mr. Pistorius and myself actually
and it was very interesting for me had a
meeting on the 7th of February in 2013
at least house which was one of the
things that we always did sat on this
big dining room table put out all the
contact put out a calendar for the year
to look at all the different
competitions and scheduled events that
we can do for the year what was the main
target for the year and mr. Pistorius
then specifically asked me if I wouldn't
mind to ask the organizers if he can
have misty and come accompany me on
these two trips which for me was the
first he's never asked me for anything
like this to have one of his girlfriends
in the past accompanying on any trips to
an athletics competition I didn't put
the question to mr. Pistorius why do you
want this and you supply to me was I
actually want mr. income to see what my
world is about the pressure that I'm
under how I need to perform and also
that she can understand better why I
sometimes cannot go to specific events
or functions with her that I have to
have enough sleep in order to train and
perform at the level son required to
perform it back in 2009 Oscar Pistorius
made this cameo appearance in a video
for Italian rock band negra Mauro his
role would later help him to impress his
girlfriend
the band's record company had another
star on their books
the Italian opera singer Andrea Bocelli
it was put to the runner than a trip to
Italy to see the tenor in concert would
be much appreciated by reeva Steenkamp
during our discussions with the
gentlemen from the music label called
sugar music which is a family-owned
business it was also mentioned to us
that they also are the music label for
mr. Andrea Bocelli
so I said to mr. Pistorius on this
occasion during our meeting on the 7th
that maybe it's time for us to call on
this favor to see if we cannot cannot
get you two tickets for you misty and
come to go and watch this concept in in
in Tuscany
now these planned travel arrangements
taking we mistaken would have a company
team did you discuss it with that yes I
did mr. Pistorius was actually very
excited and he phoned on his iPhone on a
video call actually and he passed the
phone on to me and say to Riva that if I
can please give her the good news
and I informed mr. Kham that she would
be going with us to Brazil and that I'm
also working on a trip for her to go to
Manchester with us together and how did
she feel about she was very excited and
very ecstatic about the opportunity to
travel with us to these different
competitions Pete France ale told the
court the 2012 London Olympics and
Paralympics were the making of Oscar
Pistorius a rising star before the games
but a global icon
afterwards according to his agent Oscar
Pistorius had now been elevated to the
same status as record-breaking Jamaican
sprinter Usain Bolt
not only had he become one of the most
famous athletes in the world his
earnings potential had increased almost
six-fold due to the amazing performances
of mr. Pistorius in London at the
Olympic Games and Paralympic Games
his profile was raised to global icon
sports icon status and
I think all media would agree with me
that the London Olympic Games was about
two people and that was must do psy
involved and mr. Oscar Pistorius based
on this and and and profile that mr.
Pistorius is image carried in the in the
in the business world a lot of
opportunities and a number of
opportunities came our way mr. Pistorius
I can also confirm as a very astute
businessman and he was very aware of the
role that he had to play within his
brand and the financial implications
that he stood to gain in the years to
come coming up the court hears how Oscar
Pistorius used to go to a gun range for
target practice when he couldn't sleep
you
welcome back this morning Oscar
pistorius's manager described how the
Olympian was highly concerned about his
personal security he then faced
questions from prosecutor Harry nel
about his clients habit of high speed
driving you've now explained to us why
the accused would drive at a high speed
with you with don't you know that that's
what he did you eat joke at a high speed
he drove specifically at high speed when
I was in the car when we were on the way
- the way you not - you've heard reports
that he was driving at high speed I have
heard reports but as I said I was in
witness to this facility let's talk
about those reports tell me what you
think that there was reports that mr.
Pistorius drove at high speed when I
confronted mr. Pistorius he specifically
referred to the incident that he said he
wanted to make sure that we not followed
that we are fine and that's why he drove
it I see out when the athletes reported
to you what did you do when did you
discuss it with mr. Pistorius no I did
not discuss why the Pistorius why would
you learn to drive at high speed with
other engines and not deal with in the
instance when we drove at high speed he
did not drive reckless so I didn't deem
it as reckless driving I didn't deem it
is necessary to discuss it with mr.
Pistorius said that they actually
support to you that they complain - you
know they just mentioned it nobody ever
complained to me about it mr. fan sale
then defended mr. Pistorius for losing
his temper at the London Olympics when
he accused Brazilian sprinter Allen
Oliveira of cheating in the final of the
200 meters by using longer blades
you know dealt with instances where the
accused got annoyed and lost his temper
but you forgot about that instance where
he called the person that beat him
achieved I did not forget about that I
wasn't in London during the London
Paralympic Games myself during their
specific incident I also did not have
accreditation so I wasn't allowed in the
media zone
you know I know about you didn't tell
the court about that why because as I
said in my earlier testimony that I only
explained it's about the two specific
instances where I was present with mr.
Pistorius now did you deal with mr.
Pistorius when he called the person that
beat him in the tournament that cheek
yes there was the company that we make
use of fast track in the UK that was
specifically targeted and trusted with
dealing with all the PR related to the
Olympic and Paralympic Games why must
while mr. Pistorius was in London this
incident had a long lead up from April
already in 2012 mr. Pistorius was
contacted by various athletes that's
competing in his same class and more
specifically the single amputee guys
that stated that because they can only
have because they have one normal leg
and one artificial limb they cannot
change their legs whereas the specific
athlete that is referred to here changed
his legs from different events and the
athletes felt that this person is not
playing the faith and mr. Pistorius took
upon himself to then contact the IPC and
specifically requested that there be
more specific guidelines as to what is
allowed and not allowed mr. Pistorius
himself subjected himself in 2007 to a
severe battery of tests to prove that he
didn't have an advantage and he stuck to
that specific leg so he always played
within the rules but he lost his temper
on the time telling the court that
because of the run-up he did it
deliberately no stories lost his temper
on the day that's all we're dealing with
we don't deal with so you're saying he
lost his temper but there's a reason why
not his thing
but the court then heard that at the
games mr. Pistorius his roommate was so
annoyed with him he asked to change
rooms
there was an incident that I read over
at the Olympics away mr. Pistorius
roommate asked dude
they allocated a different room do you
know about that I am aware it was made
aware of that by the team management of
the South African team and the reason
the man gave was that mr. Pistorius
would be constantly on his phone
arguing with people and he couldn't take
it anymore that's what I read no one
specifically mentioned that mr.
Pistorius was constantly on the phone to
me again what the as far as you consent
what was the reason why did the man want
to leave the room well the specific
athlete I don't know even who this
specific athlete was that this referred
to must have had his reasons why he
wanted mr. Pistorius to do to not share
with you it was never specifically put
to me that that is the reason why this
person wanted to leave the room around
our specifics mr. mazzaglia avoiding the
question as you said there why did he
want to leave the room but such an easy
question he wanted to leave the room
because of Oscar being on the phone as
mr. Naylor stated and let me read in a
report now I'm worried because you
specifically 6:34 questions ago as you
never knew that was the reason now you
want to furnish that as a reason now
Maury
mr. fan sale was asked about his clients
passion for firearms I've never seen him
carry a gun never knew even that he was
taking part in shooting activities at
shooting ranges or anything of the
nature he talked to me about that when I
saw mr. Pistorius carrying a gun and the
specific incident was Winnie was at my
residence I asking why I was carrying a
gun he specifically replied to me that
he's carrying a gun because he's fearing
for his own safety did you ever read an
article
we're a British journalist visited mr.
Pistorius at his house and mr. Pistorius
said to him that he would go out at
night to the practice range to practice
shooting if he couldn't sleep
I read this article at at some stage I
cannot recall specifically when but when
it was published at I did read an
article happy did you discuss it with
mr. Histories I did not discuss it with
mr. Pistorius did the article that I'm
talking about would you say that was a
positive or negative article that you
read at that stage I didn't see it as
anything negative that was for me a way
that mr. Pistorius could go and spend
time by himself not sleeping
well today we've been given the
fascinating insight into the private
world of Oscar Pistorius by one of his
closest associates to discuss today's
evidence with me
I have former South African detective
Lobo - nervous and former QC Kubus van
Roy and gentlemen thanks very much for
joining me Lobo first of all tell me
about what you made of mr. ban sales
evidence well obviously as evidence is
directed to help his client and he
wasn't forthcoming with all the
information you had when he gave his
evidence in chief what did you think was
missing well for instance he never
mentioned the incident with the Olympics
where the accused made a big who law
about the previous runners blades and
that was just left out conveniently but
brought up under cross-examination only
then now it was interesting wasn't it
Kobus that we heard in cross-examination
from Harry now saying he was surprised
that the defense that have brought
forward a character witness this late in
the game how unusual is it to have this
kind of character evidence this later on
in the trial firstly there's nothing
unusual ever in this kind of case and
this has happened many times before in
other cases it's not the first time he
could have asked the postponement if he
wanted one and what is more the defense
is there not to prove its case but to
create a doubt and the judge in the in
with her too
people sitting with earlier they had
people who have to decide so they have
to look at the whole picture and you
could I remember when I acted as a judge
calling in their witness right at the
end to check something and that's
perfectly within the image but we're
right down to the last few witnesses now
love-ru was telling me you're surprised
by the evidence that we've haven't heard
in the defense what do you think has
been missing well the beginning of the
case said that he would bring evidence
to court proving that the sound of a
cricket bat and that of a firearm was
similar now yesterday he had an
opportunity to use his sound engineer to
prove his theory and it wasn't done at
all wasn't even mentioned and my theory
behind that is because it's not true
there is no similarity between the two
and that's why that evidence was not
available and in terms of the continuing
cross-examination of peak fan sale how
much further do you think that Harry
Nell can go with this well there's a lot
of room for Kerry to ask a bunch of
questions about his integrity as a
witness because witness is supposed to
be objective and there's a question of a
better in terms of the case as a whole
what have you made of the defense's case
there are some people who've said it's
been a bit bitty some of the expert work
appears to have been done very late in
the day briefly both of you what have
you thought well I sometimes find it
difficult to distinguish between the
defense witness and the witness for the
state which is never a good sign Kobus
remember the state only puts the facts
before the court needn't win the case
all the facts should be brought before
the judge and then they will put all the
facts together and that would hopefully
lead to this grand correct conclusion
and once it wraps up we have a break and
then they come back for closing
arguments right yes so we're still some
time away from having a verdict in this
trial so as it is the defense is drawing
to a close and remember that we will be
bringing you special programs
evening in which there's evidence and a
full round up at the weekend for now
though goodbye from the toilet
you
you